understanding the challenges of people
living with Alzheimer's dementia and
helping them feel welcome and part of
our community is the goal of a newly
relaunched initiative called dementia
friendly Clark County it's an effort
everyone is being asked to join
there's a lot of stigma around dementia
and Alzheimer's as a whole unlocking the
secrets and erasing the fear around the
debilitating brain disease is just part
of the mission of dementia friendly
Clark County Cody Yamada is on the
Education team I think one of the
biggest components that's missing is
that part of inclusivity having those
folks who are living with dementia who
are still able to you know voice their
concerns voice the needs and the things
that they want to be heard and how we as
a community can be supportive of them
organizers say building a dementia
friendly Community takes everyone
individuals businesses the medical
community and local government all
coming together to help create an
environment that's welcoming and
respectful of people living with memory
problems or other cognitive challenges
the community that works better for the
people with dementia works better for
everyone Dr Dylan Wendt is the director
of the Cleveland Clinic Lou rouvo Center
for brain health a Cornerstone of the
movement bringing residents together to
support their often misunder understood
neighbors he says the time patients
spend in treatment for their dementia is
a very small portion of their overall
journey of the disease and to the extent
that we are seeing them here taking
great care of them here and yet sending
them back to homes that are unsuitable
for them stores that are confusing to
them streets that they cannot navigate
they can get lost on to the extent that
we don't pay attention to that we're
really not delivering care Jeffrey Klein
with Nevada Senior Services helps people
with aging disabilities lead safe
productive lives and provides resources
for caregivers he says people need to
understand the disease to care education
is so important because people are
afraid when they see people's behaviors
not being quite what they think it
should be in our current world it makes
people concerned and respectful actions
with heartfelt concern is also dementia
Friendly's goal keeping people with
dementia living as independently as
possible while staying safe and made to
feel welcome in the community that is
their home getting involved doesn't mean
that you have to become an expert in
dementia it just means you have to care
that people with dementia are out there
that they're living their lives in your
shop or in your neighborhood and that by
helping them you help all of the rest of
us
well if you'd like to register for the
first Dementia friendly meeting being
held next week Wednesday you can
register at
dementiafriendlynevada.org and we'll
have that link on our website with more
information and our website of course is
8newsnow.com really do hope that more
people will take an interest even if
you've not experienced it if you're not
a caregiver if you haven't been or if
you haven't even experienced it in your
family yet or maybe only from a distance
the more educated we all are I think the
better off and the better our community
will be for it and I think also you know
depending on your interaction with other
people if it's a member of your family
whatever the case may be maybe the
warning signs aren't as it's not a
sudden thing it's a gradual right so if
you know what you're looking for ahead
of time right that can help it can
recognize it and a lot of people live
very long lives with gradual dementia so
a lot of people are are out there still
trying to live as independently as
possible so and I think we can all help
with that important